[Música]
isso porque não fica o sono mesmo vou
aproveitar para fazer aqui um blog e
também explicar por que eu não faço
muitos vídeos que conduziram ao lançar o
melhor deixam o cabelo hoje eu quero
fazer uma lista de coisas pra fazer
nenhuma dessas coisas vai servir pra
quinta próprio deus está tudo louco aqui
embaixo e não respostas postadas né
alguns dias na casa da minha mãe porque
estou num processo de mudança de casa e
desatam você mora muito tentar encontrar
a casa ligar para as pessoas para marcar
visita e na maioria das vezes a casa
pois é muito gosta inclusive vou morar
lá com alguns de outubro como as coisas
estavam em aberto pois já da informação
e eu tô em casa da minha mãe passar
agora este dias porque eu tô mudar as
coisas no estúdio lá pra cá ou lá pra
casa que é quem não tem feito feliz lá
no youtube porque estava a uma conclusão
está um caos habitats arrumado tem muita
gente a entrar porque eu sei lá por
ocupar a secretaria vai lá fazer outro
negócio vai lá fazer umas obras e eu
tive que ir lá é porque vai fazer outro
projeto aqui e não vou ter que arranjar
uma casa pra mim não é um mal porque eu
já tava procurar deixar uma casa mas não
previa bem agora porque o canal estava a
sobrinha de ter batido o rival seja
seriam só tem um destaque
eu acho que seria muito mais muitos mais
uma das coisas que eu tenho que fazer é
muito organizado é preciso fazer uma
lista e tentar cumpri lá hoje o que
precisa fazer é ficar em primeiro turno
é porque mehldau round mês mas que é
preciso fazer e preciso de arte do museu
uma resposta mais robusta setores não
têm
participar de um projeto se ter o cabelo
pintado né
antes disso queria imagem que pode se
criar o seguro porque as coisas más
coisas fizeram tudo para demonstrar se
juntar o que já tenho aqui porque já
atuam das coisas do studio k para casa e
eu quero demonstrar sua constante e mais
mais mais mais mais mais nas coisas mais
complexas e outra coisa muito rápida se
encontrar mais casas e eu não gosto ou
eles não aceitam a proposta portanto vou
ter sempre tentar encontrar a casa do
fla com isso sempre que não porque tenha
ficado aqui mas essa casa você está
vendo não é quadra para gravar muito
triste não tem casa só comunicado a
administradora última ele está lá e que
embateu com a conversar água e sem expor
aquele com a dor estas casas menores
ela assina isso é tudo escuro cair no
auge e como podem ver estou quase no
escuro só tem esta pelo deputado do
quarto é exportar todas as noites porém
na casa do bairro cabana lá em cima
portanto você passar pelos morre e pelo
espírito do mundo larissa enfrentará
o pessoal da playboy do retiro e vamos
fazer o nosso conceito seguros que o
usual de ensinar um estilo que sempre
guardo para mim só 32 na gol e assim
você tem porquê do naruto e outra coisa
então isso que eu quero mesmo cumprir
hoje é corresponsável equipamento de um
simbolismo muito gordo e as premiadas
com muito porque ultimamente porque eu
acho que está na hora mesmo
o primeiro vai começar a alimentar um
saudável em uma dieta que o negócio
porque eu acho que o mercado caminha
douro button
a única coisa que eu acho que não comer
carboidratos nem açúcar e carboidrato
contou com duas bananas móveis roupas e
gostosa né não
só umas questões deverá dar muita
gordura e guardar no meu irmão não era
sempre é bom que a gordura vai
substituir os carboidratos que eu não to
começo do pão da fruta não sabe todo o
estado
é importante porque 57 política ou
trazer um dia depois do instituto hermes
ao solo tentado aquino com honras da
casa nessas casas tudo estava muito
turista que tudo continua lá com
materiais produzidos milhares em todo
evento muita coisa me trair luxos
bonecos brinquedos muita coisa inclusive
senti uma coisa nas estrelas que hoje
minha mãe dando lugar a um prédio
próximo dia 14 e fica muito louco
os fios do telefone documentos folhas
contratos mais casos luís deve ser mais
caro do ano termina sem muita coisa que
uma dessas caixas de ácido e então
pensei em muita confusão do dano moral é
muito popular mas é claro morra israel
provisório utilizar que tenha internet é
um exclusivo de estoque 1 com o inter
vai tentar no entanto usar com a bola e
sm federal bilhões representam outra
coisa que eu tenho que fazer é pegar um
carro para o pc quando ele ainda estava
a usar o meu segundo pcp se espalhou e
por isso eu preciso achar um cabo e um
capitão alimentação é isso aconteceu
enquanto aqui muita gente também dá para
contar com o jovem a ninguém estamos
chateados não ficava muito tempo no
estúdio fazer os vídeos dele ajudaram a
fazer os meus mas como nós queremos sair
do estúdio eu também disse que seria
possível volta para casa deu entretanto
percebeu que era o meu segundo a pcr o
crude está mais complicado fazer as
coisas já estão na onda dias acontecer
mas eu acho que é um bom sinal eu digo
isso porque sabe que eu tenho uma onda
das drogas que vem muita coisa boa
porque não preocupa nessa direção só
saem só vai falar da conquista uma coisa
que não vai ficar muito mais essa altura
agora no youtube e netflix médico
infantil
entretanto demonstra um estudo também e
como ela está e quiserem acompanhar mais
o que está a passar-se como integrante
vai ser muito grande aqui embaixo silmar
solo que era o maior número de vocês lá
porque daqui para frente eu vou começar
a fazer história também portanto passa
em la paz 11 8 unidades sejam novidade é
não seria companheira mesmo que eu vou
contar o que falar muita coisa lá e
também foi longe das idéias que eu vou
fazer e dos filhos como fazer portanto
antes
a gente do mundo onde portugal do brasil
pronto todo mundo saber que vocês que
estão lá não integrando você ver é isso
ficou lá e agora o que o plástico é bom
eu acho que vou chamar um golpe postura
é mais rápido e já estava tendo que ter
um pouco de estado mas agora o foco da
obra inclusive já o indicador que ia
tentar tirar aquelas de hoje aquela
porta estava aberta e vai ser um
socorrista positivo
esse é o piso estava molhado de planejar
e por acaso esqueci do carro que eu
peguei lá em casa eles que seu
comportamento pelo em cima da mesa
portanto eu acho que nenhum se eu vou
conseguir usar o pc é muita coisa a
fazer o teste do carro mas não pense que
imprensa e tem umas casas como suas
antigas que tinha sido pt e agora é o
mais triste porque a escola porque eu já
vi muitos vídeos e um brinde que muita
coisa como wall-e tudo sempre ganhar
espaço
ninguém joga há muito tempo as coisas
coisas como vocês viram aquelas caixas
né mas ele tem muita coisa que tanto
precisa contratar uma empresa de
mudanças para que não levem tudo e eu
acho que fica tudo bem pode fazer contas
na época supostamente os quais vão fazer
obra de um porque toda a gente tirar as
medidas do estudo pois combate às drogas
precisam ter dívida ou
caso a gente tirar coisas provar o sabor
do sítio mas vou ter que organizar da
melhor forma eu acho que tu de vídeos de
noite que quando a gente aqui pra caixas
nem roubar coisas então eu vou fazer
nestes últimos quatro dias eu vou passar
15 noites e 3.000 sérgio não quer mesmo
canal preparado por causa disto e eu vou
ter que fazer alguma coisa mesmo nem que
seja de vídeos noite cansado vai ter que
ser vai mais terceiro não ter sido preso
e vídeos que encomendas uma duas três
coisas que eu não vou ver agora quem viu
a ser tão curiosos mas não vou abrir eu
sei que são coisas que são importantes
para o vídeo agredindo usar várias
medidas num qualquer coisa né
ainda tenho aqui um pouquinho vou para
casa e pintar o cabelo porque o tempo
passa rápido se quiser que passam pelos
cuidados comenta o campeão aliás que ter
imenso mais indicadas para explicar isso
mas também pode explicar um pouco outro
país um vídeo junto agora tem que deixar
isso animal e vocês tratam logo na liga
porque eu tenho que ir a júri porque nós
temos que fazer as coisas pois o pt
porque acho
derrotou pôde foi ontem mas eu acabei de
chorar aqui neste sítio que não sei o
que é uma voz revelou aos anjos aqui
neste mundo fantástico zerohora.com de
lá em cima tem uma luz toque aqui tem
estilo direto e eu são controláveis viu
a sua história a cor que hoje é incrível
louise é o animal mais filtro do mundo
ela entrou
[Música]